Danielle is with us in Jackson
Mississippi hi Danielle how are you how
are you today
better than I deserve how can I help and
then step 2
I just finished after 15 months paying
off 19 thousand five hundred and eighty
nine dollars and sixty eight cents on my
student loan from free of Sallie Mae way
to go I have eight thousand eight
hundred dollars left to go on my car I
reversed the order because Sallie Mae
made me matter but I kept with it and
it's paid off I'm married my husband is
a nun once over that's very important
her marriage is shaky your husband is
what nine months sober okay good so that
has been through this as well for the
marriage is still shaking my mom told me
in February she's dying of lung cancer
I'm an only child Dave and I don't keep
going forward do I stop this snowball
and start putting money up because of my
job they've told me we have less than 50
employees and after six and a half years
they're not going on or FMLA when I have
to take care of my mom at the end and
she is dying and I don't know what to do
when I'm scared where does she live she
wanted 30 minutes for me and Madison
Mississippi so I'm spending a lot of
time driving between my job and ourself
of her at my house which is the halfway
point and in her house I'm averaging
three hours of night sleep a night
hey I'm exhausted and I don't know what
to do anymore and I thought there would
be excited about paying off the student
loans no I think I didn't save the money
and kept paying money in it okay a
second okay you got enough stuff on your
plate that some stuffs falling off your
plate kiddo
okay and there is a saying that says
fatigue
makes cowards of us all you are so tired
and you're so emotionally drained from
dealing with an alcoholic and with your
mother's diagnosis and you're not
sleeping because you're so you got to
take some stuff off your plate you just
got to decide what it is okay cuz you're
not you're not gonna be able to function
you're gonna have to deprioritize what
is most important to you and you're
gonna do some of that and some of this
other stuff you're not going to do no
getting out of debt right now is not a
big deal you can put that on hold
have they given your mom a timeline a
prognosis that's really hard lung
cancers tough that's a tough one so how
old is she beautiful woman for me how
about I'm bad okay so let's visit here's
a good way to make decisions on
prioritization okay
let's visit 10 years from now and you
look back on this time would you be glad
that you paid off your debt but didn't
spend time with your mom no you wouldn't
so they make that decision pretty easy
right when you look back on this time 10
years from now would you be glad you
spent time with your mom and it cost you
your job
maybe maybe what do you do what are you
doing for a living I'm a wastewater
treatment operator lab tech I make sure
the water is safe and we don't kill fish
okay and how long you been doing that 10
years okay what do you make about 35,000
a year okay so $35,000 your jobs are
easier to replace than to it and $35,000
your job so let's pretend that you
financially had a setback that you not
went into debt but that you made no
progress and your
come went down because you had to make
some choices to walk away from this job
because they won't let you have time off
to sit with your mom okay okay now I
kind of got this narrowed down to
there's really one thing to deal with
and that's mom because your husband's
got to deal with himself you can't do
that for him he's clean he's got but you
can't do it for him and so you can't
carry that weight he's got to do it for
himself and he is and that's a good
thing he's got nine months that's pretty
cool I like that I'm proud of him but
you can't carry that one the only thing
you can carry is that the three things
draining you getting out of debt working
in a place that won't let you have time
off to spend time with your mom or
spending time with your mom okay so the
way the drama goes down is is you change
your schedule and then your drama will
go down you're still going to have the
drama and the pain of what your mom's
facing and walking over the next few
months of that with her but by this time
next year you know you're going to be
making different decisions likely would
you agree yeah yeah she probably doesn't
have a year does she know okay so how
old are you 44 so when you're 54 if
you--if 2019 is the year from hell and
it's in your rear view mirror and your
income went down and you spend time with
your mom was that the right choice yes
okay so I would just calmly and not
belligerently and not with a bunch of
tears or drama stroll into your
supervisors office and say we're gonna
have to talk because my mom and spending
what little time she's got left on this
earth is more important to me than this
$35,000 your job so if you guys can work
with me I sure would appreciate it if
you can't you're gonna have to fire me
because my mother has cancer and I'm
gonna spend time with her so I'm gonna
take all my vacation time and then I'm
gonna take some more time unpaid and
then you're gonna have to fire me
because I'm not because I'm gonna do
this and you just be kind about it you
want to be mad or belligerent or
entitled not like they owe you something
but if you just kind of are a
a bit aloof because you've made the
decision I suspect that might be the
strongest negotiating position you could
possibly have walk away power okay then
if you have to just walk away
you can deliver pizzas and you know you
can wait tables and you can do something
and keep enough money coming in to eat
right I would like some ELISA yeah I
think you can you're capable and you're
not gonna not work at all you just got
to have some time where you spend some
time with your mother and I would if I
were in your shoes and and that these
were the choices in front of you so um
you know if you worked here we would
give you the time off because it's just
more important than a job it's just a
job
it's not your salvation it's a job will
be you know am I wrong okay you're gonna
be all right kiddo but you cannot
continue to try to do everything at once
you're unraveling aren't you you need
some rest
don't you anymore I forgot how to sleep
I just told you good trying to do so
dadgum much and make some solid
decisions let me tell you the most
stressful anxiety thing causing thing is
ambiguity not having made decisions even
if they're painful decisions making the
decision will set you free you just
decide this is what I'm doing and even
if it costs me that this is what I'm
doing period this is how it works are
you in a good church I've been going to
my mom starts with her they don't really
seem I'm not girls okay well listen get
in touch with the pastor in your area
you need a good pastor in your life
right now somebody to walk with you and
your mom through this and you might try
her pastor maybe you just haven't
connected yet
[Music]
it could be that you're not seeing
things clearly right now because you
weren't when I started talking to you a
few minutes ago so give that pastor
another shot and sit down with him and
tell him you guys need some help walking
through this that you're scared and you
need somebody else in your life and you
can make it through this you can make it
through this you're gonna make it
through this you don't really have a
choice but if you'll make solid choices
your stress will go down and you'll have
time to rest and your fatigue will drop
and then you'll make even more solid
choices fatigue makes cowards of us all
you gonna be okay you call me if I can
help you more